MATTEO VALLONE: My name is Matteo Vallone.
Is a member of the application and game business development team
My daily work is
Deal with app and game developers
So I want to be an app developer
Everyone should be interested to learn more
What are the success of successful game developers?
In addition, I will try to sum up
Several rules that apply to your daily work
I will give an example
How application developers use these rules
But before that, I want to take a moment to talk
Why do we think games and apps
Need to learn from each other
What do the two have in common?
But I don't want to take a sentence
In fact, I hope to solve this problem that cannot be ignored immediately.
Making money through apps is much harder than making money through games.
Everyone knows this.
This is not only because
People are more likely to accept paid games
Also because the game's profit mechanism is more flexible
Content and services provided
Can actually guide users to consume
The game can also sell virtual goods
Therefore, they can sell content
And priced price
There are infinite possibilities
So basically
Can be in the game in various ways
Sell ​​virtual currency or virtual goods
For applications, this is impossible
But the mathematical principles are the same
For apps and games
Leading mode is free value-added mode
This means that the equation on the right is always true.
CPI is the cost per install for users to install your app.
This fee should always be lower than the user you are attracted to.
Life cycle value
That is
When the CPI rises, the reason is
When service capabilities and user acquisition are more competitive
If you want this equation to be true
You must pay more attention to the right term of the equation.
Life cycle value is retention and engagement
Conversion rate and profitability function
But all factors are based on the retention rate
Because it’s the retention rate that brings the degree of engagement.
It can measure engagement
And help to make money
Therefore, retention is the most critical
This data from the mobile intelligence company Quetra
Explain why retention is so important for apps and games
This is based on the Google Play Store rankings
Rendered application user retention curve comparison
You can see the retention rate of higher ranked games and apps.
Be higher than lower ranked games and apps
Although the curves on both sides are slightly different
The retention period of the game is usually shorter
Because the game's life is shorter than the application
This is generally the case
Therefore, not only game developers should pay attention to retention rate.
Application developers should also pay attention to
Let me further introduce the retention rate.
Frequency is a key indicator you need to focus on when you try to increase your long-term retention rate
Because this indicator shows
The number of times users have used your app
If users frequently visit your app
Said they might like to use your app very much
They will integrate your app into their daily lives.
This means that these users have survived
They may always use your app
This image shows various apps and game categories.
Data presented by two indicators
One of the indicators is the frequency of each week.
Indicates the average number of times the user has used the app per week
Another indicator is the 90-day retention period, which is the long-term retention rate.
I have shown the tail of this curve before.
As you can see, although the data varies by category.
But no matter which category
There is a direct correlation between these two indicators.
All in all, retention is critical
Game developers know this very well
They will spend a lot of time optimizing the game to improve retention
Everyone can see [inaudible]
You will find that every successful game developer is very similar
Here are some highlights
They release new games before the public
Often will be tested first
They will choose a test market or choose a beta test community
They will spend a lot of time optimizing the game
Make various adjustments
Until a satisfactory retention rate is obtained
And this process needs a lot of screening
Many games have died in the process.
However, this also ensures the developer
Put resources into the right products that really have the chance to succeed
And the equation I showed before can be established.
Suitable product
If you did not pre-test the release
Easily measure retention by Google Analytics
Everyone can be at the top of this picture
See retention curve
This is the application retention curve
In addition, it also shows
Retention data broken down by user group installed on the same day
So you can also optimize to see how it affects retention.
All right
Let's talk about it now.
What rules can you draw from the game field and apply to your daily work?
First, focus on the period of rapid decline in engagement.
This rule is very important
I will show you the retention rate data chart again.
Because there are some notable things in it.
Everyone can see, no matter in which case
No matter how successful the application is
Most users will lose in the first 7 days
This is the time period for all apps to drain users.
In fact, higher ranked apps
Is the application with slow user loss
Especially in the first 7 days
After 7 days, the trend of the retention rate curve tends to stabilize
The difference between the applications is not big
But the first 7 days are crucial
You can see the average retention rate on the 7th day on the right.
That is after the first 7 days
The average number of users in different categories of apps is still using the app
These are the data from Quetra
You can see that the retention rate ranges from 40% to 15%.
This means an average of 60% to 85% of users
Will be lost in the first 7 days
This is because the user has a trial process
They will install a lot of apps and try them one by one.
After the first few days
They will really decide to continue using
Still on the shelf
If the app is good enough
Then the user is likely to decide to continue using
This is why the curve stays stable afterwards.
But the first 7 days are crucial
Game developers know this very well
Getting started with a new game is a very challenging thing for a game.
You must tell the user new rules, new ways to play
Reasons for concern, storyline, etc.
All this must start with the tutorial
I want to show you a video.
This is our recent and very successful game developer Pixelberry.
Their game tutorials have a very high full view rate
Among the users who started the tutorial
70% of users have actually finished
Every part of the tutorial
Let's play this video we [inaudible]
[play video]
- Player enters the game
We immediately tell them stories
And we try to use one
a more natural way to tell
We know that many players who play games on their phones
May not want to read too much text
So we try to make players feel relaxed and natural in the process.
However, after they have finished watching the tutorial
We hope they have already
Fully attracted to these characters
Then they want to learn more about the story background of these characters.
And what is going on
I think let the user in the game
It’s very important to feel that you are making progress
Especially in mobile games
Because I think for many games
As long as the player repeats the same operation
Can reach a certain level
And the player wants to be less boring
I think storytelling is a great way to make players feel special.
You can say too good to the player, and another bad guy needs you to solve it.
Or, now there is a new question waiting for you to deal with
[End of video playback]
MATTEO VALLONE: Two key aspects are mentioned in the video
One of them is a story
Game developers use stories to immediately engage players
They rely on the narrative of the storyline
Attract users to stick to the full tutorial
On the other hand, advanced
Advanced is very important in the game
Everyone can think about it
If the game continues to present new challenges to you
If you feel that you are making progress
You will continue to play
Otherwise it will feel very boring
These challenges should not be too difficult
Otherwise you will leave the game
Therefore, you should always find a clever balance between the two.
Let players be willing to continue the next challenge
But the challenge is not too difficult
I also want to show you another example.
In addition to the tutorial, this advanced and novice concept is how it works elsewhere.
This example is about
Another very successful game developer, Playdots
This chart shows the card data for their game.
This is the data presented by the two indicators.
One is the income of each player at the corresponding level.
The other is the churn rate, which means how many people left the game at the corresponding level.
By adjusting the difficulty level of the level below the red line and after the player experience
For those poorly performing levels
They not only managed to increase the retention rate
Also increased the average revenue per paying user
Therefore, the information conveyed by this chart
Of course, it’s specifically for games.
The message is that this is not just about tutorials.
It’s also about how to be in the whole game.
Present and cultivate advanced feelings
Ok, let's try to summarize some rules that apply to the application.
the most important point is
There will be a sharp decline in interaction in the first 7 days.
First, the user is exposed to a new application.
They must know how to use it before they start using it.
And understand the value of the app
You want to minimize the degree of decline in engagement
Help them stay through these 7 days
Until they may continue to use your app
So the first thing to find
Can provide value to users
But they don’t have too many features for them.
That is, the features that you can experience immediately after you show them to users.
Then you need to understand
The time to attract users
In order for users to fully experience your app
What key operations do you need users to perform?
And this requires users to engage in some interaction and input.
For example, create an account, upload a video
Find friends, add some personal preferences
That is, some content that can make the experience more personalized and deeper.
But also requires the user to complete certain operations.
You should gradually show these to users.
You should help the user step by step
Complete each operation
Instead of having them do all the work at the same time
therefore
You should also manage how users are presented.
Especially in the first few days
You don't want to scare them off with these requirements.
Or let them feel overwhelmed
This is the basic rule
You can pass this rule
Use in conjunction with user flow reporting in Google Analytics
To optimize your app
This chart shows when users use your app
Switch between different screens
You can see their activity path
More importantly, according to these red lines
You can see where the user left the app.
What are the obstacles?
Then, if possible, take steps to eliminate certain obstacles and obstacles.
So, this is a very useful report.
I want to give you an example.
The developer of this app recently redesigned the starter process
Good use of these rules
Overall, their retention rate on day 7 increased by 20%.
This effect is very good
How did they do it?
First, let’s talk about dating sites and apps.
Users need to make a lot of settings for the dating app first.
Then you can really use the app and enjoy it.
User needs to create an account
Provide some personal information of your own
Answer some personal questions
Pay attention to some people, upload photos, etc.
Users need to do a lot of things to actually use the app.
Developers redesigned their novice getting started process
Make it more natural and smooth, step by step
I will explain to you specifically.
First of all, this is the interface before they redesigned.
Ask the user to write a paragraph to introduce themselves
Upload a photo and answer some questions
Pay attention to some people
All of these operations are done in the same section of the app.
These operations are displayed in a set of modal windows and there is no clear order
Therefore, the user may feel a bit overwhelmed as if it were this feeling, God.
I have to do so many things.
To use this app
You can look at the right side.
This interface just asks the user to answer the question.
Even if the user performs one of the tasks
I feel very stressed because it doesn't look so attractive.
And you have to do a lot of things
This is the interface after redesign
After the user downloads the app
The first thing I see is 5 questions about myself.
Very easy to complete
The answer is yes, that is, swipe right
The answer is no, ie swipe left
After completing this item
The app will then ask the user to upload a photo.
If you don't want to upload photos, you can skip this step
This means users don’t upload photos.
Can also use the app smoothly
But users only need to pay attention to this point.
After that, users can start enjoying the app.
In addition, the system will also remind users
Need to complete other operations
To fully experience this app, these are just call-to-action
Users can do these operations whenever they need them.
Again, these operations are step by step.
The user will not be reminded to proceed to the next operation after completing an operation.
It starts with a small number of interactive, easy-to-finish tasks
And once the user actually starts using the app
Then transition to more complex interactions and operations
Now the user has decided to continue using the app.
You are creating a smooth beginner experience
And done very well in terms of the sense of advancement
Let's discuss how to make a profit now.
I want to talk about how the game is profitable.
Even the most successful game, no matter how hard
There will still be a large number of users
Never spend a penny in the game
Game developers also recognize this
The key solution is to determine as soon as possible
Users who are more likely to spend in the game
Then start targeting this part of the user
Even after this, after identifying the users who are actually planning to spend,
Also need to know how much they are willing to spend
This is really important
Because different users have different buying tendencies
Therefore, compared to providing unified content to all users
Targeted different users to different experiences or different products
Can get much better results
I want to give you an example that is very successful in this regard.
Space Ape, this is a very successful game developer.
Their games include "The Samurai Siege" and "The Country of Competition: The Age of Destruction"
The approach they take is
Segment users based on their behavior for the first 7 days
They are based on how each user interacts with the game.
Calculate and predict the lifetime value of users
In addition, they also based on different consumption patterns of users in the game.
And tag users by way of payment and purchase of equipment
Then they started using different kits
Target these users
Let me show you the actual situation below.
Here are all users
They are entering the Space Ape server
Space Ape starts analyzing them
Then assign them to a segment.
They have 5 segments
I will show only two of these segments to illustrate
Based on the prediction that one of the segments has medium lifecycle value
Its consumption pattern is
These users spend a lot in a single purchase
But they won’t buy in large quantities very often
Another segment has a higher lifetime value
But these users spend less on a single purchase.
Despite the predictions, these users have changed over time
Will spend more money in the game but they tend to spend less on a single purchase
And the frequency of purchase is very high
Therefore, developers will provide different equipment for different users.
A single amount is higher but
Medium lifecycle value user group with lower frequency of purchase
I will see a big kit that contains a lot of equipment.
The price is quite expensive
However, after they buy it once
May not buy again in the future
They will use these equipment during the rest of the game.
A user group with a medium amount of single spending will see a smaller kit and the price is cheaper.
However, they may come back to buy more equipment.
The effectiveness of this approach is very significant
If you want to summarize a rule that applies to the application domain
First of all, you must realize
Different users have different needs for your application
Especially their values
And consumption trends are different
If you can distinguish between these users
And use different equipment packages tailored to user values ​​and consumer preferences to locate them.
Can more effectively optimize app conversions
You can use a tool to understand your users
Understand the behavior of different segments
And think about what you can do
The tool that really makes a user-friendly experience is Google Analytics.
This is the segment generation tool in Google Analytics.
There are many options to create different segments.
I want to show you something.
The "behavior" category option
There are "sessions" and "days from the last session"
"Number of transactions" and "session duration"
You can create segments based on these metrics.
For example, there are two groups here.
One group is a user with high degree of interaction
The other group is users with lower levels of interaction.
Almost every report in Google Analytics
Will show these segments
For example, this is the income report
As you can see, there is not only one line of income data here.
But the income of users with higher levels of interaction
And the revenue of users with lower engagement
So you can really start to understand the user’s behavior
And the basis for grouping each segment.
In the field of application
In locating different users with different value propositions
The more successful one is Wish.
This is an e-commerce application
Very simple, developers divide users into two groups
One group is a less interactive user and the other is a more interactive user.
Developers are less engaged users
Recommended product packages are cheaper
Because users are really considering buying these items
Less investment and interaction required
Once the developer sees the user has more interaction and some conversions
They started recommending more expensive items.
This is very simple
But it really increased the conversion rate by 10%.
The last rule I want to introduce is
Find the right time, aim to
This rule says that the way goods are sold is more important than the goods themselves.
Please take a look at the screenshot of Pretty Simple.
This is another game developer Pretty Simple Games
They not only did the science design of the game but also did some artistic processing.
I want to give you an example.
How does this approach achieve optimization?
When we discussed the advanced chart before
Example developer Playdots
They also redesigned
Purchase process for the entire game
Overall, revenue per active user increased by 10%
Is indeed a very amazing number
Because this is a count for all users, including those who have not purchased the item.
So overall, a 10% increase in revenue per user is pretty good.
I will give you two examples to illustrate their practices.
An example is before the player starts entering the level.
They will see a card showing the skills they currently have.
In addition, it will also prompt the player to buy
Items that may be needed in the level
It does not display the entire store's merchandise
And just prompt the player to buy the specific items they might need in the level.
In this example, it is the treasure chest.
Similarly, when the player fails to clear the customs
Generally speaking, all mobile opportunities have been used up.
They will first see a button
Let them buy additional mobile opportunities to complete the level
They don’t have to start from scratch
Return to the store to buy mobile opportunities
Instead, you can buy it now and continue playing it.
By this practice developers get 6% more paid users
They just added these two call-to-action phrases.
Another example is that they are in the process of playing
Added some in-app products
So they not only show goods in the store
Also highlight the product with a button in the game
As long as the player has a need during the game
Buy with just one tap
This approach increases ARPU by 5%
Summarize the above practices
That is, we must also find the right time in the application, and we have targeted
This is more than just making it easy for users to buy
That is, as much as possible without affecting their experience.
Users only need to tap once or twice to complete the purchase
Also in the specific product that you sell with you
Extremely relevant time and location
Trigger call-to-action
What is more successful in this area of ​​application is TomTom.
They recently switched from a paid model to a freemium model.
As a result, paying users increased by 2.4 times
This is due to the adoption of appropriate transformation methods.
They carefully thought about their business model
And how to be wise
Upgrade to paid mode
I will show you how they did it.
The specific mode is that users can get 75 kilometers of navigation mileage for free.
Users can use this app to navigate 75 km
Without paying any fees
This is an actual distance measurement mode
Then the user can upgrade to one or three years
Subscriber
The first thing they do is
Always show upgrade button in app
The button is at the bottom of the app
No matter which interface of the app you can see
Users just tap
You can upgrade
Moreover, users can also see countdown miles to know their remaining free kilometers
They will see that the number of miles is decreasing, 75, 74, 73
They know when they need to click the upgrade button at the bottom.
On the other hand, the app developer’s approach is very similar to another example I showed before.
They will be at a very relevant moment
Trigger some call-to-action
For example, if the user starts a new trip
They know that users may run out of free kilometers
Because this trip is very far
Suppose the user has only 40 kilometers left
They will trigger a call to action, which says
Upgrade now?
Upgrade now may be better
Because users don't want to upgrade during driving
Or the user may not have a network connection during the trip or the user is abroad.
Reasons like this
They will also run out of users
Or trigger a call to action when you have used up free kilometers
But the important point is that these call-to-action phrases are highly correlated.
So it’s very easy to let users upgrade
Users also understand that they are at this moment
Reasons for purchasing an upgrade service
Ok, let me sum up, there are 3 rules in total.
The first one is to solve the problem of the sharp decline in the interaction during the novice entry period.
First use Google Analytics
Analysis of retention data from day 1 to day 7
Then think about the key moments that can drive users to gradually increase their input.
And think about how to introduce these moments into your app.
The second is to make full use of the application
Different user characteristics
Understand the needs of different users
You can target users in different ways.
Especially in the provision of in-app products
And for different buying preferences
The third rule is how you sell goods.
More important than the product itself
We call it
Find the right time, aim to
Not only makes it easy for users to buy, but also highly relevant
When you think users are most likely to convert
Trigger call-to-action
thank you all!
[play music]